[Music]
[Music]
you
have to meet my friend you guys be so
cute together cool what you like
how short is your hair um oh she's
definitely your type what's her name
full name okay cupid username and have i
or any of my friends slept with her
before you know i didn't get a chance
because i met her really fast
but cool looking forward to it actually
i'm all good thanks
hey you're becky's friend hannah right
i'm kevin hey kevin nice to meet you
please don't hit on me don't worry i'm
not gonna hit on you
okay so let me ask when's the last time
you had sex with a guy uh
yeah it's been a while are you [ __ ]
kidding me do you think that maybe you
just like
haven't found the right i gotta go
getting out of here before you ask about
a threesome
[Music]
hi girl human is she flirting with me
hey
hi so are you having fun tell me
everything about you
yeah i mean sort of my girl
friend brought me here so i don't really
know that many people wait friend that's
a girl or a girlfriend
friend that also happens to be a girl or
your girlfriend
how about you wait first let's examine
the facts
short fingernails check maybe she's an
artist or has an etsy shop
or has lots of gay sex heals
that could go either way really gives me
no actual evidence she's making steady
eye contact
i don't think you make that much eye
contact unless you're interested in
someone
wait a minute then again she just minded
one of those girls that experimented in
college but then one of the husband and
all those other things and therefore is
living with the secret desire to be with
a woman but in actuality never will it's
okay did you just have a stroke uh yeah
sorry uh so what's your deal
seriously though are you gay kind of
maybe you're a little bit gay because
why else would you start a conversation
with me
oh um i'm from chicago uh i like to
write are you gay
hey i am so glad you two found each
other
this is my friend hannah hi i think i
[ __ ] that one up
yeah she [ __ ] that one up
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you